previously
we watched as xander's and as l b slowly
began to lose hold of the bank
due to the streets outside becoming more
and more hostile
they were losing men and due to hardware
complications the backup of the servers
was still a long way from completion
after confirmation from bliss the lmb
broke the contract
and withdrew from the bank falling back
to regroup with another unit of nearby
lmb
over the other side agents shu and
hoskins are hot on johanna's trail
following a number of clues they've
managed to locate a building that has
the potential to be a large cleaner
facility that is responsible for the
manufacture of countless fire bombs
that have been making their way onto the
[Music]
[Music]
streets
with division agents on her way to her
location johanna contacts xander's for
assistance
she knows she will need help defending a
huge stockpile of firebombs
they've been hard at work putting all of
these together for a large op that
pharaoh has been preparing for
the plan they're going to blow up the
hudson refugee camp
and everyone inside it they know that
these camps are the number one source of
spreading the virus
all these people in close proximity to
one another spreading the disease
and free to come and go as they please
by doing so
they continue to ignorantly help the
virus in reaching more and more
vulnerable
and healthy individuals outside their
walls
unfortunately a lot of xander's men are
still recovering from the conflicts
of when they were defending the bank
headquarters and on top of this
xander's still had to brief bliss on his
current situation
and everything that has happened since
they last spoke which means there is no
way possible he can get to her location
in time
he suggests that she and her cleaners
move themselves closer to his position
johanna agrees and with the assistance
of her crew they managed to locate a
building in close proximity to where
xander's and his men are located
the empire autumn hotel
staying out of sight on a rooftop near
to the location
hoskins and shu contact amsel asking her
to provide them with some additional
support
with the raid on the cleaners she tells
them she'll head to their location with
some backup
however she explains that with such a
large group of jtf
they will take some time to get ready
[Music]
waiting at the rendezvous point hoskins
is growing more and more impatient
and much to shoe's objection she
suggests that they get closer
so they can scan the building with a
pulse just to make sure the cleaners
haven't disembarked already
immediately they noticed that a number
of personnel inside are removing
equipment from the building
worried they may miss their opportunity
hoskins demands that they strike the
building immediately
they quickly make a plan shu will go
through the office and disable the bomb
detonators with a shock grenade
and hoskins will go to the roof and
provide cover through the skylight
where she should have a good vantage
point
sneaks in and gets into position he
waits for the perfect opportunity
and lobs a grenade into the middle of
the explosives before the grenade has
even hit the ground
he is ducked into cover and is setting
up a turret
the remaining cleaners have now turned
their attention towards him and have
opened fire
unfortunately he has jumped the gun and
hoskins has not yet made it to the roof
so he's on his own and even more
unfortunately
the vantage point that she was making
away too already has someone else up
there
and they are firing down upon him
as he prepares to fall back to the
safety of outside his exit is suddenly
blocked
as the roller door slams down behind him
it was a trap
hearing his calls for help hoskins
frantically moves away onto the roof
and there she comes across a similar
face johanna
and she is the one that is firing down
on shu
raising her gun immediately onto her
shoulder she commands johanna put down
her weapon
and step away from the skylight
she keeps a gun in this position locked
onto her sister
and the two of them begin to make their
way across the rooftop
johanna moxa jeering telling her she has
no idea what it means to be a real
soldier
that the division is merely a small
hindrance in their operations
and ultimately there is nothing they can
do to stop the cleaners from completing
what needs to be done
then without warning johanna manages to
disarm her sister
and after a brief tussle maneuvers her
into a chokehold
and hoskins blacks out
eventually hoskins comes too her weapons
are gone it's quiet
deafeningly quiet and she starts to
realize that everyone is gone
calling over the comms for shu she gets
no response
getting carefully to her feet she feels
weak and disoriented
she starts to make her way down from the
roof
continuing to call out over the radio
she begins to get more and more
concerned
and anxiously she starts to call out it
definitely looks like the cleaners
are long gone entering the warehouse she
hears a voice
buried under some rubble as a heavily
injured cleaner who has been left behind
by his crew
he's in pretty bad shape burns over most
of his body
and he's unlikely to last long
hoskins rushes over to the man and
screams at him demanding to know where
the other agent is
and what they have done with him
although clearly in pain
the man laughs mockingly at her and her
chest begins to tighten in horror
suddenly isaac blips indicating there is
an echo nearby
hoskins feels herself break out into a
cold sweat
she knows she has to she doesn't want to
but she has no choice she must find out
the truth
activating the echo she observes as
isaac begins to piece together the
events
of agent shu's whereabouts the echo
identifies a heated exchange of words
between johanna
and shu which quickly turns violent
and her sister starts to fire a gun upon
him
crying out in pain as a bullet
penetrates his flesh
he tries to reason with the woman but
she is unremorseful
and once again fires another bullet into
his body
writhing in pain he begins to bigger for
mercy
but she isn't done yet coldly
she grabs a flamethrower from one of the
others and without hesitation
lights him on fire hoskins stands rooted
to the spot
mortified and unable to escape the
screams of agony coming through her
earpiece
as shu's final agonizing moments of life
are forever imprinted
into her head turning back to the
wounded cleaner on the ground
she shrieks at him to tell him
immediately where the others have gone
he is reluctant at first but quickly
changes his mind
after hoskin provides a bit of
persuasion by inflicting painful
pressure on his injuries
gasping he confesses they are heading
towards the empire autumn hotel
he also divulges information around what
the cleaners are planning to do with all
of those firebombs
that the hudson refugee camp is their
target
at this time hoskins radio suddenly
crackles
and amsel could be heard over the comms
declaring that her and the jtf
are on their way hoskins still reeling
from anger
informs her that the site is now secure
but shu
is dead
johanna heads through the sewers with
the remaining cleaners
they eventually emerge back up to the
surface xander's is there with a squad
of lmb
weapons ammunition and some defenses
ready to be deployed
johanna questions if he is there to help
he responds yes
but is obviously uncomfortable with the
situation
not long after a report from an lmb
scout alerts him to a large group of jtf
approaching the current location
johanna is prepared to take a stand and
fight them
but the plan is to load the bombs onto
the subway car and get it moving as
quickly as possible
towards the hudson refugee camp once
it's on its way
there is nothing the jtf or the division
agents can do to stop it
all she needs from the lmb is for them
to hold off the approaching jtf as long
as possible
while they get the explosives into the
car
xander's has an uneasy feeling with the
plan but nonetheless he orders his men
to take positions around the hotel
courtyard
the approaching forces are now only four
blocks away
as they head towards the compound the
agents manage to gun down an l b scout
shot in the leg he has no way to escape
them and through a bit of persuasive
pressure
he eventually reveals that the l b are
working alongside the cleaners
and helping a lady called johanna
immediately amsil confiscates his radio
before ordering some jtf officers
to remove the man and get him some
medical aid
contacting xander's via radio she
challenges him
does he really know who he's working
with johanna
his so-called ally is already
slaughtered two division agents
the jtf continued to move forward with
their assault on the compound
inside the hotel a clearly agitated
zanders tries to interrogate jahana
probing her for information on what
happened with the agents she had
encountered earlier
he demands to know what her plan is and
does she even realize
that by fighting the jtf which is made
up of police and military personnel
that they are essentially killing their
own his questions remain unanswered as
time is quickly moving
and he is needed outside in order to
help his men with coordinating the
defense
frustrated with xander's incompetence
and seeing what truly matters
and why these sacrifices are necessary
johanna instructs one of her cleaners to
prepare a collection of some of the
leftover firebombs
and place them directly underneath the
courtyard
the man is confused and states that the
majority of the l b are in the courtyard
and if by some chance the bombs were to
go off they would all be wiped out
sharply she snaps back at him to just
get it done
the cleaners have nearly finished
loading the bombs onto the subway car
all they need now from the lmb is to buy
them just a little more time
suddenly the gunfire from the jtf ceases
and they can be seen hunkering down
outside the compound
and holding their position xander
suspects the agents are up to something
and he's right far beneath the compound
the agents are finding another way in
the agents have come to realize that
whenever the cleaners abandon a location
that they do so by utilizing the sewers
so surely now
and especially given the current
circumstances they yet again will be
doing the same
hoskins sends out a pulse wave which
identifies the jtf above them
and the lmb in the courtyard and within
the hotel
however that alarmingly also detects a
number of explosives that have been set
underground just ahead of them
and the man that has set them up is
still down here
on top of this the pulse also reveals
that a few of the cleaners are sneaking
up behind the jtf
as the agents begin to piece everything
together they come to the realization
that by applying pressure to the back of
the jtf the cleaners will undoubtedly
push them forward and into the courtyard
once inside they will be trapped and the
bombs will be detonated
killing everyone within the compound
including the lmb
frantically they start trying to radio
through to the jtf
but the signal is blocked their only
chance
to disable the bombs before the cleaners
have a chance to set them off
quickly they start moving towards the
explosive devices
but the cleaner who is setting them up
has spotted them he attempts to radio
through to the rest of the crew
but he also isn't getting a signal the
agents continue to move forward
they must disable the bombs as fast as
possible but also vital
they must stop the cleaner from getting
back and alerting the others
amsel goes after the cleaner while
hoskins agrees to get to work on the
bombs
as she has some experience with
disarming these types of explosives
but it's pitch black down there and
hoskins is struggling to find the
location of the devices
her pulse still needs to charge and the
cleaner is getting away
eventually she manages to locate three
of the four bombs and disarm them
at amsel's suggestion she also takes the
triggers away so they can't be rearmed
by the cleaners later
however the fourth bomb is a little
different and hoskins is unsure of how
to tackle this one
yet given they are running out of time
she has to make a call and decides to
pull what she guesses is most likely the
correct
wire unfortunately this causes the
device to go off
although thankfully it doesn't explode
but the agents quickly realize that the
area around them
is quickly filling with gas due to lack
of air circulation within the sewers
they are forced to immediately find a
way to the surface before they pass out
they come across a ladder knowing full
well they could be about to expose
themselves to the enemy
but despite this fact they are dead if
they remain down here
with agonizing uncertainty they quickly
became their fateful ascent
up towards the surface they find
themselves coming up into the middle of
the hotel courtyard
and immediately they are surrounded by l
b soldiers
xander's emerges from out of the hotel
to speak with the two agents
amsel this time to his face questions
him on what exactly he thinks he and his
l b are doing
and eventually they've shown the
triggers they pulled from the detonators
xanthes can't believe that the triggers
are from bombs that are located directly
below him and his men
that jahana was planning on sacrificing
the lmb
then without warning bullets start
raining down upon them
johanna is mercilessly attacking them
from above
while in his attempt to take cover
xander's is struck by a bullet
and although hoskins attempts to save
him a major artery has been hit
as he bleeds out onto the pavement of
the courtyard his mind remains focused
on his men
and he instructs his lieutenant to get
him to safety whispering to him quietly
he says they're yours now russo before
dying
shortly after devastated by the
senseless loss of his captain
the lieutenant is disgusted by johanna's
betrayal
johanna indifferent and without any
remorse instructs them to begin
targeting the rest of the lmb
at the same time the lmp lieutenant is
declaring that all remaining cleaners
need to be eliminated every last one of
them
meanwhile hoskins and amsel head down
into the subway following closely behind
and rapidly departing johanna ahead they
spot the subway car
piled with explosives and realize it's
slowly starting to move forward
and in front of it is a cleaner who's
blocking their way with a flamethrower
amsel decides to take on the cleaner
allowing hoskins to advance forward
toward the subway car
she reaches a subway car just in time
and quickly climbs aboard
it has started its journey towards its
unsuspecting target
as she attempts to make contact with
amsoil she detects a loud bang
reverberating through the subway
then over the radio she hears the other
agent's voice
amsel is alive but she's been hurt it's
all up to hoskins now
johanna is the last cleaner left and she
too
is on the car once again the sisters
meet face to face
pointing their guns at one another
johanna remarks that even a single stray
bullet would be all that is needed to
set off the napalm tanks
she congratulates her sister she truly
has surprised her
she never would have expected this much
from her in the past
hoskins ignores these remarks and tries
to instead reason with her sister
but it's a waste of time deep down she
knows her mind is too far gone
johanna legitimately believes that this
is the only way to save everyone
that by blowing up the people and the
refugee camp thousands of other lives
will be saved
it's all come down to this and she
always knew it would
the one person who could get close
enough to johanna is the one person who
would find it the hardest to pull the
trigger
and end it all the lives of the refugees
versus the life of her sister a choice
she never wanted to make
she fires a gun the bullet tears through
her sister's chest
knocking her backwards and onto the
ground hoskins stares at her
mortified what has she done how could
she do this
her own sister johanna looks back at her
in surprise
why she asks not understanding how it
really could have come to all of this
hoskins cries she didn't have a choice
she couldn't let her do this
and that some things really are bigger
than ourselves
johanna tells her that it might be a
good idea to pull the brake
hoskins quickly runs two and pulls back
hard on the lever
the car will squeak and screech before
eventually coming to a stop on the
tracks
returning to her sister johanna smiles
up at her and remarks on what a good
shot she is
immediately hoskins drops to her knees
and pleads to her sister to let her help
her
johanna brushes her off stating that her
bleeding is internal and there is
nothing she can do for her
hoskins calls over the radio requesting
immediate assistance to her location
refusing to give up and together for the
first time in a long time
the sisters seem at peace with one
another
i know i was always the better soldier
says johanna
but you have always been the strong one
the division
they made the right choice with her last
breaths
she apologizes telling her that she
loves her
before dying shortly after
at the surface hoskins instructs a jtf
officer to clear out and decommission
the bombs in the subway
but to leave the body in the car
untouched
eventually amsel shows up though looking
a little worse for wear
she explains that ever since she loaned
hoskins her phone that it's been going
off non-stop
with that remark she hands over the
phone hoskins recognises the number
it was her husband who was calling
quickly dialing the number back
she manages to reach her husband and
lets him know that she is okay
she even has a chance to talk to her
little boy however she ultimately has to
tell them that her job isn't yet done
but she hopes to see them very soon
after returning the phone to amsal
the agent tells her that she's proud of
what she's been able to achieve over
these past couple of weeks
and if she's ready there is an agent on
the other side of town who is in need of
assistance
if she's up to it she needs to get on
her way now but unfortunately amstel
won't be going with her
instead hoskins will be taking along
another agent who is yet to have any
experience in the field
someone who has been activated from out
of town and brought into new york to
help out
and it would be her job to bring him up
to speed and teach him the ins and outs
of what's been happening
in new york city
as i mentioned in the first video of
this series this has just been my
narrative point of view of the hearts on
fire audiobook
i strongly urge you to check it out on
audible.com
casey weyland katie sakhoff shannon
woodward and the rest of the cast have
done an amazing job on this
and i've really only just summed up what
is a fantastic division story
from here i'm likely to drill down a
little closer into the detail they've
given
us and potentially overanalyze the extra
information would be provided throughout
the story
there have been a few insights that have
potentially spoken a little more around
what was available to the first wave
agents
and perhaps a few flaws in what we've
learned about the shd over the last few
well many years that the division
franchise has been around
anyway i hope you've enjoyed listening
to the story as much as i did and i'll
catch you in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh